good morning John so the thing about the
way that I'm getting chemotherapy is
that they really dose you it's just
super hard on Friday and then you get
one Friday off and then they hit you
super hard again on that Friday after
that and the whole idea of this is that
the four different chemo drugs that I am
taking they do a good job of interfering
with cells that are currently in the
process of dividing a lot which are
cancer cells but also some other cells
and so it makes you feel sick like it
weigh disproportionately kills cancer
cells but it also kills normal body
cells and so that makes you feel
terrible and they want people to stay in
treatment and not feel too bad and they
also want to minimize complications that
you do get if you have too many negative
side effects piled on top of each other
and so they let you recover and I'm
feeling so like normal right now before
they smack you back down which is
happening at 9 00 a.m tomorrow morning
and this schedule turns out to be very
good so far at least for Vlog Brothers
so like I have a full week of recovery
before it's time to make the first
vlogbrothers video which maybe I'll do
next week and then I have two full weeks
of recovery before it's time to make the
next vlogbrothers video fantastic and
here's a weird thing by like day six
after treatment I felt like a hundred
percent of the bad feelings in my body
were because I'd just been lazy and
spending too much time in bed not
walking around enough not getting my
body moving and I was achy and I just
felt gross but dear Hank from the past
and also Hank from the future you felt
bad because of the keema I feel much
better now and I'm just as lazy as I was
a week ago it's a weird thing to do to
your body I mean top five weirdest chemo
side effects hiccups from the
dexamethasone which actually isn't it's
kind of a chemotherapy drug but mostly
you take it to hold back nausea and feel
a little bit better after getting your
treatment hiccups intractable hiccups I
probably had like 2 12 bouts of hiccups
last more than 30 minutes over the
course of two days it's miserable red
urine which you might think I'm dying
but in fact is just one of the drugs is
a red color and it can come out in your
urine and also your sweat which makes me
ask what kind of person is sweating
during chemo like I am not exerting at
all but yeah you can get enough of this
drug in you that your your sweat is
actually pink like a freaking hippo
hippos have pink sweat
it protects them from the Sun
so they don't get skin cancer maybe
salivary gland pain didn't realize that
that was possible the moment I saw a
dish of food I would it would hurt
because my salivary glands would
activate and start creating saliva and
for whatever reason they were recovering
from injury and it was physically
painful to drool I thought I had a UTI
but it turns out chemo can just make
your urethra hurt
is that TMI I don't know the last this
one is super normal and I don't I just
had never heard about it but your mouth
gets sore like you could get so bad that
you can get sores in your mouth which
hasn't happened to me but you're like
your tongue feels bad and you're under
tongue like everything in your mouth
just feels sore none of those however
have been the worst side effects for
chemo for me I've been very lucky to
have been spared nausea had a little bit
but nothing big but I've had a headache
the entire time it's much less bad than
it was but for me the biggest and
hardest side effect is just the fatigue
it does not feel possible to be that
tired and I've I've felt that bad like
during when I had covid it was a similar
feeling of fatigue it is hard to move
your arm enough to grab the Gatorade
bottle getting up to go to the bathroom
was work and you might think Hank he's
putting on a brave face during his chemo
but no I'm not I feel better now because
I'm on the last day before I get
walloped again and very importantly
different people's chemo regimens are
very different people respond
differently and people are taking
different drugs so I'm not trying to
represent like the universal experience
here and they say hair loss begins day
14 which is tomorrow so I told Lauren
about the hair loss and he said but when
does it grow back and I told him you
know it's going to take a while but it
will grow back and he felt fine about
that so if he feels fine then I feel
fine everybody should feel fine John
see you on Tuesday and here's some
pictures of some flowers and bees that I
took in my garden
it's very nice isn't it
I'm glad that this happened when the
weather was nice it would have been
miserable in the winter can you believe
this freaking flower
I think I'm on a journey of meaning